[Music]
in cabin crew code news what a hair have
income how they reset Captain Crunch I'm
off submitted by in your Dean's we miss
between budget airline easyJet I've
never heard of them
what I think it might be Europe made the
British airline has revealed the bizarre
hand signals its flight attendants use
to communicate with each other oh I
always wonder what those gang signs were
what I've never seen them you never seen
the two like kind of like doing that
kind of [ __ ] this but I always assumed
it was just like an I all type of thing
I saw one flight attendant look at
another one and do their stereotypes is
true about pilots and flight attendants
very promiscuous creatures with each
other we're with each other with the
staff with everything as long as they
wrapped their tools they should be fine
what tools the penis you ever had an
itchy dick and then you go on WebMD and
then you get even more scared because
all the pictures look like they're dicks
about to [ __ ] burn off oh I think
it's WebMD everything has gone Google
Images anything everything is Connor is
the flu of the dick that wasn't okay
easyJet CD
yeah that's TV yeah it's so easy jet so
back in May that was a Twitter user that
tweeted out at easyJet excuse me but
please explain what on earth is going on
here and then they added this video to
that tweet you know
I've never seen bat [ __ ] that should
look like some baseball game plays right
there I know that stuff's not meant for
the passengers though right
no no so then that's why this this
passenger was just being nosy oh filmed
it and then they're like what on because
I feel like that's the same passenger
we're like if the passengers witnessing
like a police raid and then the police
guys were going like this whatever I
notify all the criminals and now the
hall rate is destroyed that reminds me
you're better at this now but you you
always ruin whenever I'm trying to be
discreet about something like whatever
you're like huh what I'm like oh I'm
[ __ ] discreet uh so first of all
Mexicans do this thing right
so we I'm gonna do it with my fellow
Mexican I'm gonna go like this
what does that mean I mean later what's
up yeah exactly you know what you guys
like this he's like he's like wait what
are you trying tell me something what
exactly do you go when you go what's up
I'm letting you know I'm cool
everything's good what about you yeah
like we're trying to communicate so
she's not gonna do it back if I go like
this she's gonna like reply or say like
say nothing or tell me that what's going
on good to me so this is my reply you
know it's not so that's that's us going
like what so we both didn't know Mexican
the way I do I mean you're responding
with what knows what and I'm saying
nothing no you're not what usually
nothing is nothing
yeah you got like this nice that is the
universal no in context when do you use
that so it's like something's happening
and you don't want to be obvious right
yeah like listen you guys are talking
and I noticed there's some tension or
something there's multiple situations
but for example there's like tension
they're not looking you know just be
like and then you would be like I'll
tell you later or nothing like you're
telling me like I'm lower in the middle
of something and you like um later like
that I will do it
here okay okay there's tension here so
they're fighting attention here right
stop it the render my job no I'm gonna
always at the review so now he walks
away and I'll look at it and I'm like no
be like yeah scream what he didn't know
that the difference he's not a girl
that's a girl be different all the time
I grew up in the nineties right with the
backpack blow the butt okay where is it
below the back you would walk down the
hallway and you see your homie yeah
exactly
it just means hi though you know yeah
that means hi this great Jesus I thought
you were telling me hi like me how you
do whatever see I'll tell you what's the
scream look here at I know I know
yep more floor ah discreet guys do have
this great language though because
that's not really does everybody
understands that [ __ ] tell you what guys
connections is so I have a friend named
gob oh right we were in this Davao
Hispanic restaurant there was this man
large man I probably exaggerated his
height right now but to me he seemed
like he was seven foot eight so he was
his big dude tattooed up there's this
little girl acting up right he comes up
to go he goes a tell your [ __ ]
daughter to shut the [ __ ] up right this
little sweet girl and that lady comes up
to him she was probably but three feet
tall she goes hey don't [ __ ] talk to
my daughter that way and he goes I'll
[ __ ] beat your ass to me and Gobbo
we're eating we look at each other we go
thank that bad
we go back to eating do you know what we
said there you don't do [ __ ] I don't do
[ __ ] we're gonna get [ __ ] up go back
to eating that's exactly what we said
and they walked out nothing guys do this
with strange stranger guys there's a hot
girl walking by oh yeah if me and Bart
don't know each other there's a hot girl
walking by and then we both see it and
we look back and we like because we're
strangers but that's not discreet you
from Afghanistan
I'm from [ __ ] universe yeah there was
a whole conversation that had that's
world peace right there I'll show you
nonverbal communication that's all we're
trying to get it yep yeah so now easyJet
was saying that for the past 21 years
they've learned all these different hand
signals for different things and so I'm
going to show you guys this was like an
emergency [ __ ] rolling this is a
training video for the crew here yeah
they should come out with all cute [ __ ]
like this was annoying yeah
but there's a [ __ ] on aisle three hey
this won't bleach this face only want a
chicken forget anything to eat or drink
them at him Hey right away oh that's
dope
[Music]
haha bacon forget a proposal stag party
Oh
what someone stuck in a thong oh you
must fight me Greta you know what's dope
it's very commonsensical yeah come in
Pensacola people can read it like like
other people can understand yeah it's
not like like police Park where it's
like like whatever like this and that
means like we're gonna blast this place
up or some [ __ ] yeah they can't be
yelling at each other across the thing
either so they need that [ __ ] especially
when people are trying to sleep they
can't be you know I see it that's time I
like how it's really big movements -
it's not like you know like police or
like I feel like other airlines they
have like smaller gestures just like
like this but they're like what if they
see a terrorist or like that make sense
because diners have diner talk so they
played people will probably do sign
language is dead yeah playing people
when you call them again lame people
flight attendants yes for saying
stewardess yeah I don't like plane like
oh no play people and then you know like
like what's the call diners and stuff
what you want like a hamburger some be
like can I get a dead cow in a flat or
some [ __ ] do that to this day I'm pretty
sure some oh gee people still do that
job on again if you order like like Chow
mains I can I get like two skinny asian
people on a plate yeah the first time I
ever heard that talk like in a movie it
was Emperor's New Groove when he was
like trying to take over for the show or
the waitress something I don't like they
talk like that cuz I still see it on
like diners drive-ins and dives like on
the East Coast with some of these older
establishments like it was like a Philly
cheese place and if you wanted their
Philly cheese without with Wiz versus
mots or something like that they would
have a shorthand yeah yeah can I get an
ugly Italian on a dead cow or something
more work though cuz you have to like
decipher the code it's like just save
the order I don't know I don't [ __ ]
know but that's like what they like to
do or something so probably keeps his
job fun yeah dude I thought it was gonna
be like secret insults that they came
out with it would ever
we wouldn't tell their training I know
but that would have been so much better
would you have hey hey desert does a
Chinese guy on aisle three you open up
your wallet bet they give their cheap or
if the guy comes out like the tomato
soup like who is a four yeah like like
you know how there's always a crying
baby like crying baby on how three just
be like baby we have our own secret
signals here do we yeah like this like
oh all right Coco
Oh your arms cut off Casey oh it's
actually uh very discreet thank you see
and it would be like mmm or like if
you're because you tend to go out of
frame all the time I have to like pull
you under the table I could just put
over here that's true whenever so my
favorite discrete signal that we do here
is when Joanie's to get ryan's attention
he takes this [ __ ] recorder just goes
[Laughter]
are you guys you guys are always like
doing things in in it under the table it
always looks like Jill's beating off bar
holy we're just holding in oh really
do I look relaxed Africa I have discrete
foot signals for yourself was it that
the most interest thing you've ever
heard and your whole entire life I don't
even know what you guys just talked
about but anyways please subscribe for
more random videos more funny content
and more hahaha
poopoo in your pants stuff go ahead
subscribe and for more videos right now